gave
proof
[Music]
does not
[Music]
for the land
[Applause]
[Music]
flippy from indiana flippy from indiana
please unmute you are on the air my
friend all right can you hear me
yes i can hey david it's me um i just
was wondering if you've ever
reconsidered making an only fans
sorry if i if i've done making an
omelette what no no making it only fans
uh you know
uh gardening season is over and it's
time for you to show us your zucchini
[Music]
that's very clever no listen um i think
i'd be more likely uh i'd be more likely
to show my
my granny smith apples than any zooks
floppy dukes flippy floppy uh floppy
dukes
floppy dukes flippy
five and a floppy inches all right
welcome everybody whoa
[Music]
i don't even know where that's coming
from
oh my god what was that uh
that's not a song i've ever heard very
very strange
a welcome everybody we have two
huge events taking place here joe
manchin
is going to be helping move forward on
debate of the expansive voting rights
bill that we've been following now for
weeks and weeks and weeks
and we also have the uh aftermath
of the ethan klein stephen
crowder and sam cedar meltdown that took
place
yesterday we are celebrating everything
with a very special one-day coupon code
cold feet crowder uh heretofore
unpromoted coupon code we're going to be
talking about
all of it let's take a quick listen to
what's going on
on the floor of the house uh the senate
nothing okay
i guess they're voting on voting on
whether to move forward
with debate which will subsequently go
to a vote
which some may oppose all right so a lot
of different things a lot of different
things going on here
uh okay so we're going to keep an eye on
that but we are oh look a lot of no
votes here see
carolina no
that's uh is that tim scott and lindsey
graham
okay so that's going on votes on voting
for subsequent voting and voting related
actions
okay so i'm gonna just wait a few
moments before we get into the entire um
sam cedar thing it's it's really wild
it's very very exciting stuff but i have
a few different things to go over with
you guys
first of all as many of you know last
stream i debuted my new
stream deck which allows me to you know
switch between shots with the click of a
button
and um you know put certain things in
the chat
and all sorts of different stuff one of
the things i mentioned was i want to
start building up a library
of audio drops now people saying use
number pad
come on guys we're running a
professional stream here or at least
trying to
um one of the things i have here is my
audio drops and so last stream someone
said well you should have ymca ready in
case you need it which i do now
and then somebody also cut up and
cleaned up some nice
um trump fraud
drops for me so now i have three
versions these could be dropped in at
any time here's number one
oh the audio level is way too low on
that yeah the level is something we need
to work on but okay
fraud fraud it's a fraud
so those are now available um i'm
actually getting a new
the compute you know how a windows
update has sabotaged a whole bunch of
different streams
i'm getting a whole new computer system
today so i've not really built out too
much of this stuff
because i'd have to start over with the
new computer which we'll have up and
running but by the end of the week
but if people have other things i should
have available in my library or in
general people who know about
it's a fraud how you can use the stream
deck to improve streams
start sending me stuff okay guys fraud
exactly exactly so we've got that going
on
um let me see what else i
had oh i do have a new this is really
great this reminds me it's just a black
screen i know but
this is a song that was put together by
jr
uh for the show it has in my mind a
jimmy eat world
vibe take a listen to this this is great
[Music]
if you're thinking about joining the
david
pakman show he's got a lot of
content don't you know
search a subject but don't forget to add
his name i love it the end of the
subject
he'll hit you with some facts
empirical at that
and once or twice a week he'll mention
about
his gardens pretty good garden now but
it's not for everyone
you should also know
that there is a bonus show oh my god
people are not loving this i thought
this was going to be just a hit that's
that's actually depressing
i guess i really don't know the audience
[Music]
producer pat will give his take which is
a pretty
decent perspective pat knows what he's
talking about
[Music]
if you're thinking about joining the
david
pacman show he's got lots of
content don't you know
search a subject but don't forget to add
his name
at the end of the subject if you're
thinking about
joining the david pacman show
he's got lots of content don't you know
search a subject but don't forget to add
his name
at the end of the search criteria all
right well if people don't like it i
guess we it doesn't have to become a
regular part of the show but
man that's depressing i thought people
really liked that would like that
ah horrible horrible i guess i just
don't know the audience
all right so there's that we got that
out of the way
um a bunch of different inquiries about
uh what i've done with my bitcoins i've
done nothing
there's there's been this big price drop
that went all the way down
under 30k for the first time um you know
i'm not a trader
i've been holding my bitcoin for years
and years and selling
five and ten percent tranches now for a
very long period of time
i'm up multiple x from the original
investment everything now is the house's
money
i'm just holding it you know it's like
either it'll be worth nothing
and i've only got a few percent of my
total assets in it and so like
by the time it goes down to zero i'll
have made it up elsewhere
or it'll go wild again you know i'm just
saving it it just that's
that's all i'm doing there uh what else
do i have
oh a woman demanded
to speak to the manager of the airport
in indiana i don't even know what's
going on here a viewer sent this to me
earlier today let's see if we can get a
little more zoom on that there we go
here we go
[Music]
why isn't she wearing a mask also like
everybody else is i don't know
oh this is an old clip i didn't realize
that it i just was sent it today this is
a five hour old
[Music]
post
who saw him choke me to the ground who
saw me
i saw you run through the door when you
weren't supposed to
push you out you just
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right it's a fraud so anyway that um
that's new to me
that's new to me sorry guys uh i guess
that's not
new um i'm flying this weekend i hope i
don't have to deal with this stuff
um milo yanapolos is now
opening a gay conversion therapy clinic
i guess
um i'm not sure if he's licensed
but that's going on a month or so ago
i tossed my engagement ring into the
pacific ocean
remember milo is heterosexual now and i
moved
to florida florida i'm here
partly to share my testimony
uh here on true news but also what
better place to share testimony than on
true news obviously
to open a center a clinic for
other men who have been suffering from
same sex attraction
suffering can you you know most of them
wouldn't they wouldn't say they're
suffering
raising money fundraising has begun
we imagine donating by the way summer
we'll be interviewing
therapists and thinking about where in
florida we should call home
okay so i mean
it's it's it's yikes central yeah
exactly right
um okay
believe it or not that woman is an
oncologist the woman going crazy in the
airport that's depressing if true
uh all right so that is that let me say
a few thank yous a bunch of people
signed up via twitch i want to say
thanks to give me your milk please
neptune maul bury
astro lycos flea girl
chill small fuzzy moss
fluffer stumps that's it
okay very good new members one through
six today
also because we are celebrating uh to
the extent that it's worthy of
celebration this entire stephen crowder
fiasco we do have a
one-time coupon code available at
joinpakman.com
the coupon code is cold feet crowder all
one word
i'm in a sale lower case to keep it
simple really the
the case doesn't matter but it sounds
more interesting
and whoever the first person is to use
that code
we'll get a free item or item depending
on your pronunciation
from the david pakman show store at uh
on our website let's look at a few other
super chats here chris says
absolutely love the idea of anti-prageru
please provide coupon codes that
increase the cost of membership
well no i mean you can just drag the
slider and pay more we don't need a
coupon code for that
that functionality is built in love your
show keep up the good work love that you
guys take much needed vacation time
seriously very important to take a rest
if needed yes we will be on break next
week but i will probably stream the
saturday night trump rally because i'm
so
morbidly curious about it i thought the
song was pretty good different vibe than
the regular music
haters gonna hate glad you like it david
maybe if you put drums to it people
would like it more
i should do that still trying to figure
out how to get that all set up
um okay and we are momentarily going to
get into the uh
steven crowder stuff i just have a few
other things to go
over um oh as
promised the new youtube channel
we now have all of the thumbnails are
this well almost all
uh are this new style thumbnail we went
with the yellow
so if you're just scrolling through your
feed you would know
that this is the live channel because
it's in
yellow rather than blue and in the upper
right corner it says
pack live hello instead of pacman
okay so the entire team doing a really
really good job
with this and you can find the new
channel i have a button for that
and i just linked it in twitch and on
youtube you can also just go to
youtube.com
pacman live we do have our first 5 000
subscribers on the new channel
and um it's going well i mean listen
we're just building this thing whoa
there we go we're building this thing
from the ground up
all right so let me put that a few times
in the chat beautifully done
and we're continuing to build that but
yeah we've got our new format all set up
and i'm liking it i'm liking it
and much coming to the new channel
okay very good as far as that goes
before we jump into the crowder stuff i
do have a couple of other voicemails oh
whoa hold on a second
big dump of memberships orlando silva
just signed up with the coupon code cold
feet crowder at joinpakman.com
thanks orlando um uriah
arrowwood just signed up with the coupon
code
cold feet crowder at joinpackman.com
and mason labonte just signed up with
the coupon code
cold feet crowder at joinpackman.com new
members
7 8 and 9. very much appreciate that
also thanks to sven hout angelo sanz
uh both of you for the twitch
subscriptions appreciate that as well
and let me just get to a couple of these
voicemails some of the usual suspects
um and then also some uh some other
people let's listen yeah someone needs
to tell
sam speaker this is troy you can and i
hope you don't do a video of this
that these protests against bolsonaro
are just
globalist health industrialists
all right yeah nope nobody cares about
uh troy york
here's another one hi mr defender singh
um davinder singh jeez
that's that's i think a pet name for me
i'm just wondering
um in regards to all this
rhetoric about overthrowing the
government and
citizens taking up arms against the
government it's a
fraud um all right so this guy most of
the audience is bored with
um let me see what else i've got
i think this is the egg man hey dave
yeah regarding uh ronnie jackson and the
montreal
cognition test and republicans that all
say that joe biden has dementia and i
want to test him
um i don't know why that's even an issue
for them i mean didn't they
have ronald reagan as their uh
president's
elect or the president fake the
president idol and then they ran the
country behind him
his wife did it all the republicans did
it he had dementia
he had cognitive problems everybody knew
it and even afterwards
they would brag about how they ran this
country this is true
republicans still idolize a president
who had
early stage dementia when he was
president that's a that's a fair point
uh doesn't seem to be a disqualifier
um ooh there is a new caller that has
called in
one two three four five six seven eight
nine 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18
times in a row do i even dare click on
it
oh no 19 20 21 22 23 24 25
oh my god
do we even do it
let's try no no no no
i've worked in inglewood i'm legally
blind
i've been in 20 different psych boards
all over the city i know what the mental
health
situation is in chicago
ooh i don't know about this
that was a bad way to do it to pronounce
my
campaign you you know
but but i love chicago chicago has been
there for me my whole life
so that was a three-minute voicemail
then called back my point is
yes i might be running for mayor because
because you know i mean if trump can
become president
someone who's legally blind who went to
the army
i think i'm going to get away from that
for now we need to
we need to vet that a little bit um and
let me see if i have anything else from
the standpoint of
voicemails
but yeah since the black people are
wanting reparations
for slavery i think that we should burn
all the british flags
and not use brighton's flag anywhere
anywhere
at all like i don't want a reminder of
this [ __ ] [ __ ]
and it was like it needs to be toned
down like
a great deal and then for them to take a
lot more responsibility
all right so continued verbal ink blot
tests happening on the voicemail line
and we are officially done with that
thank you to kay
guldi for subscribing via twitch prime i
appreciate that your new member number
12 today also thanks and welcome to
stephanie weber who just signed up with
coupon code cold feet crowder good today
only
timothy norville just signed up on my
website with the coupon code cold
feet crowder and lobotomize me daddy
just signed up with coupon code cold
feet crowder
all at joinpakman.com new members number
13
14 as well as 15.
okay let's get into the sam cedar stuff
so i'm not going to give a full
background to this but for people who
are who are
you know if you're familiar with it you
already know the background basically
sam cedar has been trying to debate
um right wing comedian i guess he's a
comedian i don't know
right wing comedian steven crowder for
years now
i first became aware of this i mean
actually before this was even public
back in the last politicon which was i
guess 2019
i was already aware of this because i
talked to sam pretty regularly
and um i don't even know where to start
but
he was sort of on route to debating
stephen crowder as far as politicon had
told him and then crowder bailed and
then we found out crowder's dad didn't
think it was a good idea
the whole point is crowder was very
actively avoiding sam cedar
and kind of pretending to not even
really know who sam cedar is
but as is revealed in this clearly
he knows exactly who sam cedar is uh
ethan klein
friend of the david pakman show from the
h3 podcast
arranged for him to debate uh stephen
crowder
even though ethan doesn't really debate
and then through subterfuge
he brought in sam and sam appears
and crowder is visibly having like a
sort of anxiety
type response so let's just jump into it
and we'll comment as we go
so we've got a little surprise for
steven crowder so let's all
enjoy the debate here we go i'm really
glad to have
my next guest on the show and i've
always said this i always respect people
who um
by the way at first i thought crowder
was wearing a bra of some kind
like either some kind of a man's ear or
um like uh they have this bra for
posture
i didn't but i guess it's a gun he has a
gun on the show
i don't know if that's part of the
comedy joe rogan told me when i was on
with him that
crowder's a comedian enter into the
arena um
and you know we've had a lot of debates
on this show which is different from
like it changed my mind where we sit
down with conversations
but uh mile brazil if you i think that
crowder does
anticipate this because they tried it on
him like the day before last week or
something because
he's doing this very particular breath
where i do think he knows what's coming
and he seems very extraordinarily
anxious here
in jiu jitsu i said if you come switch
we go switch
you go spicy we're gonna do a little
spicy yeah so we always try and uh
keep it as respectful as possible and i
really do appreciate the guy making the
time because a lot of people haven't
has a huge youtube channel several
youtube channels one of the ogs
a lot of people watch them uh you know
some of you like them
some of you don't same can be said for
me ethan klein from h3h3
uh ethan thank you thanks man for making
the time you're very welcome and i just
want to say i know you called me you
said that i would be a layup
[Music]
and i think you're right because i don't
think i'm a very good debater
i think you know that so uh i don't want
to make it too easy for you
oh okay so uh i've prepared
okay yes all right so what we're going
to talk about
is what we were going to talk about is
you know the initial quote that happened
i think he's looking off there uh the
initial so i think here crowder kind of
knows what's going on and he's breathing
really really heavy
i think he knows exactly what's about to
happen kind of was turned into
um a little bit of a meme which wasn't
intentional
and uh was you saying you don't even
have to think about it
regarding the cdc uh and i disagree with
that
like what crowd is making no sense even
in explaining what the debate is about
and i think it's because his mind is on
something else
um i think people should think about it
i believe and we'd set talked about this
through playful ribbing and an
aggregation
of medical authorities and scientific
voices to make an informed and rational
decision
um it's like dude what are you talking
about right now what on earth are you
talking about
so where do you think that i was that
i'm wrong on that
stephen do you know that um the spartans
are
that they are like a practice man love
with children
oh jeez okay so this is what's going to
happen i t what did i tell you he was
going to do anything he could to avoid
oh oh there he is oh no sam cedar what a
what what a [ __ ] nightmare
i had no idea this was going to happen i
thought i thought ethan was a stand-up
guy
so notice that right as soon as this
happens this other dude walks by in
front of the of crowder's camera
and then for some reason i don't know
the camera just goes to the other guy
maybe because crowder's talking to
someone off screen about how to deal
with this
yeah i told dave dave remember i told
you i told you i said this i guarantee
you he's gonna do anything he can to
avoid the debate
i just think he believes that he should
debate you no no he doesn't he just
takes advantage of women with you know
mental health issues
doesn't stand up and to his own fight
right
let's bring on fm you would
uh do anything to avoid talking to me i
think you're
the point that you make is
really clear about something for me this
is just
comedy like what i mean by that is um
you know it is true like nobody has a
responsibility to debate you
any more than i have you know an ability
to demand
that a school invite me to speak or
whatever like there's no doubt that
crowder
has gone out of his way for years to
avoid sam cedar
i am not huge on the validity
of the ambush much the same way where
you know i've been aware many times
of politicians i'd love to talk to of
their location because of conferences
that i've gone to
politicon is an example we're all
staying at the same hotel at politicon
right so
if i want to go and ambush chris
christie or whoever
i can do that but for me i don't do the
ambush because
it's it's merely a comedic element for
me it's not a
you both people have to agree to the
conversation so
this is a 13 out of 10 on the comedy
scale yeah
the ambush stuff is really not for me
and if crowder doesn't want to talk to
sam
he shouldn't be forced to talk to sam so
absolutely brilliant comedy but
the fact that it doesn't get into issues
if someone did this to me
i'm probably also not getting into
issues okay
there's no idea that you were taking
your show off it's just a play it's this
is just rhetoric who can come out on top
rhetorically last time coming in today
with your
pig pen peanuts i wish everything
you take those off with a velvety
buttons
now is velveteen someone i saw a super
chat here
saying that something is anti-semitic
there
dave pirovich says cold feet crowder
used a cryptic anti-semitic reference
velvetine
rabbit eyes yesterday during the
meltdown
i i'm not familiar with that reference
uh let me look that up
um
velveteen rabbit
hmm i'm not
seeing there are some things oh hold on
there's a post about it
unnoticed anti-semitism from crowder
this is let's look at this this is a
post actually on reddit
i do want to see what this is about
i noticed in the recent podcast episode
with stephen crowder some anti-semitism
may have gone unnoticed by sam and ethan
directed at sam by stephen and his
co-host it was odd
steven manages to quiet everyone and get
their attention then instead of making a
point or debating
he requests sam remove his glasses it
was odd and confused both sam and ethan
with sam looking visibly confused he
then says to sam i want to see if you
have the little velveteen rabbit buttons
which adds to the confusion because it's
not really an expression but then his
co-host also mutters or if there is a
soul it then dawned on me
that velveteen rabbit eyes are just
shiny black half globes
and that crowd crowder and his co-host
are insinuating sam has soulless beady
black eyes a common anti-semitic
stereotype i had to google to see if sam
was jewish
yeah he is because i'm not racist and
you can't tell if someone is jewish
based entirely on appearance
lo and behold he is while black bdis
aren't the most obvious or well-known
stereotype of an ashkenazi jew
it is listed on wikipedia as one
documented in nazi propaganda
as one in both writing and constant
depictions
this was some subtle racist [ __ ] that
stephen crowder decided to come at sam
with
probably because he was scared and can't
actually debate anyone outside of a
college freshman properly
so he resorted to subtle racist insults
and then fled probably to try to get his
dad to go beat up ethan and sam's dads
i've attached some sources on black
beady eyes okay
interesting that's that's interesting um
so it looks like this super chatter
was absolutely correct about that okay
let's continue
i don't know why no one would be here
[Music]
why has crowder been off screen this
entire time show your co-host ethan
you should be yourself ethan how can you
respect yourself as a man
brother stephen you are such a coward
stop showing your little leprechaun
co-host who comes out dressed like
your sidekick ethan
let me hear what pig pen has to say here
really quick fair enough ethan ethan
look i
i don't hold on a second ethan this
because i came out here to talk with
ethan
come on man look the same reason that i
haven't ever had a conversation with sam
cedars the same reason that uh joe rogan
uh sam harris brett weinstein dave rubin
ben shapiro don't own
anything it's based on a lie ethan just
like you claiming my
that's thunder and i may lose power okay
if i lose power you guys just keep
watching this over on h3
ethan what's the you claiming
[Music]
sam why do you feel that anyone owes you
air time when you have a 40th of the
audience and you've been doing the show
i think anybody
every time i think i think that ethan
has just given it to me
i didn't ask him for it and so you've
been begging the real questions
it's amazing how crowder offhand knows
exactly
the proportion of his audience size and
sam's
like he's not coming up with that on the
fly
he he's clearly very familiar very
familiar with sam's show
so he can build his example your
audience
cares that i only have a million
subscribers and you have what
six or seven million subscribers let me
answer can i answer your question can i
answer your question can i answer your
question
sure you want me to answer your question
my audience would say sam who
just like joe rogan's audience and ben
shapiro so of course that's really silly
for a number of reasons like
i'll bring people on this show that my
audience hasn't heard of
if i think it'll be an interesting
conversation the audience cares whether
it's interesting
not if they know the person um
and and so this entire thing is kind of
a non-sequitur dave reuben
because you had to shoot on yourself
every day that you do that uh
let me clarify sam let me clarify the
change in my mind everyone knows on the
show right we've had
professors i ended my show last week
stephen if your
audience because you're an idiot and
half of
congratulations
that
i don't know if this has been said
before but i
let me think how to even say this um
sam is absolutely telling the truth this
is an important thing to understand
sam is absolutely telling the truth
that politicon told sam
the crowder debate was happening okay
that's
absolutely true that politicon told sam
that
the thing is uh politicon
lies a lot okay and i don't know that
i've said this before i don't know if
politicon is going to be furious with me
and they'll never have me back
because i'm explaining this whatever
but politicon has also lied to me
about things that were booked because
they say oh yeah yeah yeah that's
happening in order to keep
things moving forward on the assumption
that they'll later get everybody to say
yes so let let me explain to you
okay um the i you guys know i'm behind
with sam on all this stuff but
this when i was doing politicon in um
i'm guys people say sam has receipts
sam's not lying it's pr it could be that
politicon
was lying and i'm gonna remind you guys
of this i was supposed to be doing a
debate at politicon
it was going to be me and kyle kyle the
king kolinsky
um with on the other side charlie spork
i'm sorry sorry charlie kirk
and candace owens now as all of this
this was i think
2018 maybe i think it was 2018. all
along
now he now all along politicon was
saying to me and to kyle
guys this is happening you and kyle
versus candace and charlie kirk
i already had reason to believe that
candace owens was never
going to agree to a debate with me i
didn't believe it when politicon was
saying it
and i said it to kyle kolinsky i said
dude
i don't think this is for real and he
said i really don't know uh let's just
wait let's just keep going
and later when politicon said hey yeah
can you sign your contract and agree to
all this different stuff
i said you know it's not written here
what we're doing you told me we were
debating charlie kirk and candace owens
that should be in writing
then they say oh yeah candace actually
isn't going to be able to make it well
hold on a second
you told me i was definitely debating
candace
and then now you don't mention it's not
happening and you're trying to get me to
sign on the dotted line
i think the truth is candace was never
doing it and
later candace owens was actually asked
why did you bail on the debate with
david pakman and she said
i was never going to politicon i believe
her
i believe her i don't think she ever
agreed to it and
it's something that it's a very common
thing when you're trying to get a bunch
of personalities together
you just tell everybody that everybody's
already in and you
then try to use that and then they go to
kansas and they go david pakman
kalkalinsky charlie kirk they're already
in
et cetera et cetera et cetera so on this
particular issue
sam is absolutely telling the truth
politicon told him the debate is
happening with crowder
i believe it's 50 50. politicon
probably was lying and they were just
assuming they would get crowder to say
yes
they had no idea about the backstory
between crowder and sam
so i think it's hugely likely that
that's the case
all right so now when when crowder says
that's not true i think it's quite
plausible that that's not true crowder
has
still been ducking sam that was part of
the ducking when
when politicon went to crowder and said
do you want to do this crowder said no
so he is ducking him i just don't know
that it's true that it was ever agreed
upon that could have been a politicon
lie they do this all the time
is saying either way crowder has not
addressed sam for years no doubt i just
think it's quite plausible politic
online
they said you let me let me explain to
you let me explain to you let me explain
hey you
drop
sam fake stand-up comic who we can't
find any footage about online let me
finish stand-up comic
oh you're not okay that makes sense
because everything that i've seen is
incredibly unfunny and unentertaining
sam samuel can i answer your question
yes
so you have gone on you've done the same
thing with other other comments everyone
has a bigger audience than you
because you said i want to speak with
stephen crowder
you believe that at some point there was
some acceptance what have i ever done a
politicon
ever as a matter of fact in the last
decade
this is probably true i don't think
politicon is something crowder would do
because he knows it would be terrible
for him so again
i think almost certainly politicon lied
that crowder had agreed
for four years and stopped because they
suck they don't pay
and they're full of losers and you've
been clamoring for it and that's
something
that you dropped out of doing issues
notice the feminization crowder uses
woman as an insult this is a typical
right-wing tactic
all right let's talk about the issue so
ethan do you want to have a conversation
about the event because ethan do you
want to look at the appreciation going
to hide
absolutely so why are you hiding behind
sansitus
no no no no i'm not hiding him
yeah this is why i don't do like this
left-wing drama stuff and all of these
different infighting things because it's
like
i i already watched this once it's it's
all getting pretty boring but we're
going to finish it out
and then i see people have a lot of
questions about it and i'll answer them
these are the ones who are hiding
really this is actually
you who's the guy who never appears on
stage never does a live show but it
never even
sheds it never even allows a shadow of
comedy to be perceived on his program
it's just hiding
everything we do is out in the open h3
h3
and you're wearing the whole we agreed
so hold on a second yeah
so i want to normalize responsible gun
ownership is that your debate no wonder
you had to bring in a hack for you
you're talking about comedy
does anybody know what that's about who
who's having mentally ill women on their
show i don't even know what that means
all right okay all of us all right sam
you you got it you got it i hope you
haven't
beautiful hold on hold on hold on
hold on hold on let me just make one
point hope you enjoy politico hold on
let me make one point
take it easy don't fail guys
hey sam one thing
is this take off your glasses the bdi
juice stuff again is that what this is
about
i just want to see if you take them off
if you have if you have the velveteen
rabbit but there it is
all right good you guys are good thank
you so notice that even just in this
conversation
crowder's using anti-semitic references
he's using sort of like gender-based
sort of homophobic stuff like calling
calling sam a woman
um he what else does he do i mean i
guess those are the two big he didn't
say
did he say anything uh i guess that's
mostly it but it's only a few minutes
long
don't even take off the glasses oh it's
right all right
[Music]
he admitted that he followed the show
last week we got
him then he watched the show we got him
dude we played him so hard because he
he literally was [ __ ] that's basically
it
that's basically um that's basically
what happened
and i know different people found it
engaging and funny to different degrees
i definitely found it compelling
i do think that when the prep when the
pretense is an
ambush the person being ambushed can
sort of do whatever right like when i've
been at
in fact it happened at politicon where
people came up to me and said
with a camera and they start asking me
political questions and
i respond you know i always try to keep
my cool and i said um
you know i'm on my way to a thing you've
got to email in through my website if
you want to schedule an interview with
me i don't just do interviews on the
street you don't you don't know who it
is
i think as soon as the tactic for the
confrontation
is the ambush whatever happens is sort
of what happens but crowder did not look
good here
crowder did not look good and the
physical shaking and then the anxiety
and so on and so forth
um okay
let's see what questions people have
diego says will you watch crowder's
longer unedited version god i don't know
i watched this last night and now
i don't know that i have the the
interest in
another version of it megan says it's
about the frenemies podcast with trisha
mentally ill women is a reference to
frenemies podcast with trisha
okay bill says thanks david love your
content
charles says there's a tweet
screenshotting all of the liberals and
leftists that crowder has debated
that all have less than a million subs
total bs
excise ironic as sam has routinely
excused the numerous anti-semitic tropes
espoused by ilhan
omar we should be consistent i haven't
heard that but i condemn
all anti-semitism everybody here knows
that
if crowder wants to call someone else a
layup and debate he should be willing to
go the full nine who with someone who's
familiar with debating
why is he anxious i thought the gun
protected him
steven crowder mentioned sam cedar had a
million subscribers but i thought most
of the subs were russian bots
uh okay and then we got we got there
jacob says quote i have no idea who sam
cedar even is i just watch his show to
see if he ends it early watch enough
episodes to know he never allows comedy
and wait until his show starts before
i'll call into ethan's show
yes exactly the point is crowder was
saying leftists don't debate
yeah i agree i agree it's all
just such bad faith nonsense completely
agree with everybody
let me get caught up on a couple of
these um things that are going on
we are celebrating the sam cedar stephen
crowder fiasco
with the coupon code cold feet crowder
all one word all lowercase
a bunch of people just signed up on my
website with it anthony emma just signed
up on my website with the coupon code
cold feet crowder junie mcgraw just
signed up with the coupon code
cold feet crowder elizabeth howandzak
just signed up with oh a different
coupon code fresh start
and jeffrey rodriguez just signed up
with the coupon code
cold feet crowder that's four new
members which i appreciate
um also want to say thank you to some
twitch subscribers
sam the sleazebag has just signed up
david
chadman now a 21-month member
junk saint gifted a sub
control alt delete has signed up
uh margot cabot has signed up e lawrence
mf jonesy as well as simple choices
and ranch fiend that's seven
very much appreciate that as we take in
the absurdity that was this really i we
can't even really call it a debate
now this is a good point crowder's game
is ambushing this is a prank against him
in the same way
i i didn't know that crowder ambushed i
mean i guess
i don't know that the prove me wrong
thing is an ambush but if he does ambush
then it's a taste of his own medicine
for sure
let's listen to what's happening on the
floor of the senate just a little bit
here
as we move forward on debate on the
voting rights bill let's listen
of tax returns and and whether or not
congress can mandate candidates for
president to release
their tax attends i
i think it's only reasonable that they
should do so
but the concern that i have is that the
constitution is really pretty clear
in outlining the requirements to be
president
and releasing tax documents is not one
of those so it kind of presents a
challenge there
can we direct that um there's an issue
requiring states to re
to create redistricting commissions may
also
be constitutional since congress cannot
coerce or commandeer the mechanism
wow okay so that's happening and
are we are going to continue keeping an
eye on that
uh crowder has ambushed people you can
easily find it all right let me see if i
i mean let's take a look crowder ambush
i don't know
steven crowder ambushed
almost everything that comes up is
the stuff about this does anybody know
how i could
crowder confronts okay right yeah he's
not using it
crowder confronts let's look for that
crowder confronts slandering sjw
professor what the hell
all right let's take a look and see what
this is about i have a feeling this is
going to be pretty ugly
let's see where the ambush actually
starts
conservative students behind closed
doors
i'm not a guy who wants to destroy a
man's life suing him for verifiable
repeated attempts at libel
but at this point what choice did i have
my professor
oh it's a whole segment based on these
uh confrontations
okay yeah okay so this is a taste of his
own medicine then
and you told someone what happened last
year
was during spring break of last year
see if this happened to me when i was
teaching i wouldn't just pretend like
nothing's going on
and can continue teaching like that i
would just call security
[Music]
yeah i understand but spring break of
last year for this man
that i said when he
[Music]
threats to my son yes one said i
threatened your son
when my son was receiving death oh
security does get called
yeah yeah this i'm just not into this
stuff
let's see when does security show up
what a mess guys
ah there we go changed my mind and some
of the
locations sure is night follows day
after we filmed this video we sat back
and waited for charles hermes to do what
he does
lie again i'm fortunate to have a
platform
but keep this in mind if i don't have
this show if i'm someone like you
and this person makes these claims and
people believe it you don't have a job
you never work again your reputation is
ruined forever
all right well yeah i mean listen it
does seem like this is it it seems like
that is his strategy then
so i take back if you're making i just
am so
you know i don't watch any of this crap
um if he's ambushing people all over the
place then that that
makes sense that he would at some point
be on the receiving end of that to taste
of his own medicine so to speak
i want to say thank you to thorsten
herman who just signed up on my website
with the coupon code cold feet crowder
also cal moultin just signed up with the
coupon code
cold feet crowder and cameron halls
just signed up on my website with the
coupon code
cold feet crowder let's see what is
happening now
in the senate debate about the voting
rights bill
madam president is when i got up this
morning the farthest thing from my mind
was that i was going to have a chance to
see you today
and and since i am seeing you today
madam president i want to say
thank you i want to say thank you uh
for your role uh in this administration
in leading the bite administration to
make a proposal that was
passed in the american recovery plan
that's going to cut childhood poverty in
this country almost in
you can tell that the senate is more
collegial than the house because they
often do this move where
the hand goes in the pocket while
speaking that's a real
senate move you don't see that as much
in the house from the very beginning was
one of the original sponsors
of that legislation and even though the
president's budget has has said we ought
to make it
extended to 2020 to 2025
i just want to let you know madam
president that we're still fighting here
to make it permanent and i think we
should make it permanent we've already
had
this is why i'm here today but we've
already had columbia university tell us
that
there's going to be an eight times
annual return
on the investment that we make as part
of the recovery
because instead of mitigating for the
problems of kids
in poverty we will actually be
eliminating poverty for almost half
the kids all right so now there's just
some sucking up to kamala harris going
on here
uh man what a weird uh what a weird day
huh really really strange stuff
comrade mamdani saying cower with
crowder
uh what is coming up as far as
interviews oh so to
no not tomorrow on um thursday
i'm interviewing dr eloque kenosha
who is not only a psychiatrist but also
a streamer
he's been on the show before um
but he's an interesting guy a lot of
people ask me to have him back on let's
see what he's been up
to lately um
let's see some of his clips
just to give everybody a sort of sense
psychiatrist
game streamer exactly let's see what
he's got lately
student hires dr k to deal with entitled
parents
oh that's interesting is there a
confrontation that that sounds pretty
compelling
let's see what that's about
there the noises there's crazy thunder
all over the place guys i
i may lose power all right let's see
what's going on here
see if we actually get something we
talked about narcissistic parents great
question
so we are talking about entitled parents
and so this is the first thing so let's
talk about entitled parents so what i
i want to do is explain a little bit
about my experience with
working with people who have entitled
parents and sort of how to understand
them
and what seems to work the first thing
that we're going to talk about is that a
narcissistic parent
an entitled and an entitled parent is
not
necessarily the same all right this is
maybe not the example i was looking for
i was looking for one where he's doing
you know
actual uh discussions with people
let's see if maybe we sort by
most popular talking with lily pichu
i don't know who that is talking with
reckful
god i have no clue who these people are
i know pokey
pokey's a uh you know she's in the
pacman show universe
asmin gold michael reeves does anybody
know who these people are
xqc i know penguin z no idea
talking with an incel about starting a
relationship let's check that out that
sounds interesting let's just dive into
it
yeah i mean by the crowd or standard i
shouldn't be talking to this guy because
his youtube channel is only one-third
the size of mine
and what am i let's just jump in here
and just because you don't believe it's
feasible doesn't mean that you don't
want it or you don't fantasize about it
it doesn't just said talk it's high you
know
this is a british incel okay sure
yeah okay so let's just put a pin in
that for a second so help me understand
a little bit about
so your quote unquote problem
is that would you call it a problem is
that you haven't been able to find a
girlfriend
sure that seems like a problem oh he's
not british
you don't seem to be identifying with it
this is a common uh you know therapy
technique you just wait sometimes you
just you just don't respond right away
and then you see what comes next
can people tell like i mean listen i'm
argentinian in argentina everybody has a
therapist but
grew up around a lot of uh psychiatrists
psychologists
what makes you say that no stephen
kenneth destiny bonnell the second's
expertise is actually
a pediatric social work not a
psychiatrist oh just
your response maybe mistake on my part
so would you say that that that's your
problem
yeah i think so okay
so help me understand kind of hard to
nail down but yeah
it if you gloss over the details and a
high level that is the problem yes
okay um so tell me about the details
guys i gotta tell you this is pretty
freaking compelling the details
then yes so that implies that there's
something a little bit more complicated
to your situation that involves the
details so
let's talk about the details yeah
i don't really know where to start with
that though okay
so tell me um
can we pause for a second okay
oh boy
[Music]
okay can you just tell me a little bit
about uh where you grew up
um so now they're sort of like going
back to establish some rapport
let's skip ahead a little bit with me
but we did anyway and i just hang out
and hung out with them and did the
things they liked to do
which included like more of that but
also going clubbing
which is like much harder than just
hanging out in a bar like i hate
everything about clubs
but like is this guy british or not i
kind of can't tell
everything about them um but yeah
we did all that for a little bit until i
got until i got tired well
actually eventually they moved so
eventually they one of them went off to
australia and the other one
somewhere else at around the same time
and we when we split then
but for a little while i tried that and
didn't it didn't appeal to me and it
didn't work out for me but i was just
i thought i'd give it a go yeah very
good right so once again you're a smart
guy
you logically looked at your situation
and you decided that you were going to
try something
and so it sounds like you that have you
tried that a couple of different times
or that was sort of the main time
uh yeah so i just went i just went on
that little binge it was like a few
months of just going clubbing with them
and drinking with them
okay um
did you meet any did you meet any girls
during that time
no so no i didn't although
one of the guys was was pretty good
looking and and
he he got off with a few but for
whatever reason his other friend didn't
then he was
almost at least to me seemed almost as
attractive and uh
but him and me didn't know
how how do you understand that like if
if his body was also it sounds like he's
outgoing and enjoys clubbing and
is attractive like why didn't he meet
any girls over those few months
let's talk about him for a second so
what the other guy who didn't do any
better than i did
yeah right why didn't he
yeah i guess i never figured that out i
mean why didn't you do well
let's start there well i mean i'm
overweight
okay i'm balding i don't if you know
i don't know how clearly it comes
through on the web sure i think you've
got just standard male pattern baldness
oh god okay so anyway dr k is going to
be joining me um
on thursday and i don't even know what
we're going to talk about but i am he's
been on with me once or twice before
and so that'll be um i think i think
that'll be pretty interesting
yeah that the guy's microphone had like
all bass it's really weird absolutely no
trouble whatsoever
i want to say thank you to adam david
lee mecco birdo
shody for signing up via twitch and
twitch prime and
associated uh mechanisms i also want to
say a huge thank you to george davidson
who just grabbed a membership at
joinedpakman.com with the coupon code
cold
feet crowder that's a today only thing
and lastly thanks to brian
brostick who just signed up on my
website as well new members
33 and 34.
some other super chats coming in i'm
worried about dem's chances in 22.
dem voters are getting complacent and
the gop trump supporters are energized
this scares me
i agree with you and we're going to be
talking about that a lot
david which presidential cabinet
position do you think is the most
powerful
or coveted well i would say secretary of
state but i think actually in terms of
all the president's staff
chief of staff may be the most uh the
most
in a sense coveted
hi david is this critical race theory
uproar bad faith
stuff that i've talked about a lot
including earlier this week
so i don't want to go into that right
now steven's
soup mix crowder chowder powder
nice very nice people will unfortunately
gravitate towards reactionary positions
as some form of catharsis which is why
crowder and his ilk have many viewers
sad
charlie baker says he's leaving the
republican party sick of this is that
right
let's see charlie baker leaves gop
not seeing any reporting on that
i'm not seeing that um
not sure if i just got trolled so it's
kind of
boring but okay let's uh get back to the
senate
debate here institutional and taking
away the rights of states to admin or
administer their elections i find it
hard to believe that it's anything
but a motivated attempt to federalize
the nation's election system
the for the people act would achieve it
through a
number of i think overreaches i'm only
going to talk about a few
for one voter id
the for the people act did you say i do
render null voter id laws across this
country
instead of an id which most of us have
and virtually i think every citizen
should have
you'd simply just sign an affidavit to
say you are who you say you are
i've heard the georgia law for example
brought up as
providing egregious limits or
obstacles to proving who you say you are
in a hearing a month or so ago
we had an official from georgia in a
judiciary committee i said could you
explain to me
what the what the challenge is
so if somebody gets a an absentee ballot
like you do in north carolina we have no
no excuse absentee balloting we've had
it for years i've supported it i've
voted that way several times
we had people say that it was just an
egregious imposition
to note a 10 or 12 character
driver's license or government id number
on the affidavit
that's all it is you don't have to send
a copy of it you just simply have to
write a number down so if you have an
ink pen
i guess you could argue if you don't
have a writing instrument
then maybe that's who still uses the
term ink inkpen by the way
that i don't think i've heard that in a
really long time there's a law
that has been castigated by some of my
friends on the other side of the aisle
they even provide for people who want to
vote who may not have a
government-issued id
other documents that could be used in
their place
we've talked about hundreds of bills
that have been filed by republican
legislators without a single democrat
vote that are like the georgia bill that
i just described
which i think is arguably a fair bill
but most of these bills are things that
democrat and and republicans should be
able to agree on you should cleanse your
voter rolls you should make sure that
people who have died people who could be
registered this is kind of a red herring
that they do where they say hey you know
what
lots of states purge voter rolls to get
rid of inactive voters
that's not the issue the issue is what
is the rubric
or the barometer that you use in order
to do the purging and when you get
extraordinarily aggressive with it
that's where the problem is
it's not that it's done at all it's that
it's being done in a particular way
id requirement that 80 of americans just
this week at a poll said they think is
reasonable
now you have to also understand that we
make accommodations if you don't have an
idea in north carolina
we moved heaven and earth to make sure
you need a government-issued id
i believe to be able to move through
society
to get a hotel room to get on an
airplane i had to provide i had surgery
a couple of months ago i had to present
an id to get admitted into the hospital
i think we're disenfranchising people
from the rest of society by not at least
making sure that they can identify who
they are
yeah it's immoral not to require voter
id
um exactly exactly right luis
leon has just signed up at
joinedpakman.com with the coupon code of
the day
cold feet crowder i appreciate that also
thanks to ky
dizzle as well as manny for signing up
to support
via twitch all right guys that's going
to do it for this stream i may be back
tonight with
nyc mayoral results people wondering
what's going to happen with yang
and others so in all likelihood i'm
going to see everybody back
tonight coupon code colt feet crowder
good until midnight
we looked at the crowder cedar ethan
klein
fiasco a new york city voters are voting
right now right now and
i will uh in all likelihood see
everybody right back here tonight and
tomorrow we'll have
maybe even tonight we'll have the
results of this maybe eventual vote
that they are heading towards today see
everybody soon
what's going on now man i'm still here
how do i even end the stream what do i
even do
i'm still on just kidding guys see
everybody really soon